une renommée que j'ai qui est arrivé au
québec autour de mon nom qui est arrivé
très rapidement et cette reconnaissance
là m'a ouvert beaucoup de portes et mon
nouveau encore beaucoup aujourd'hui mais
j'ai passé plus de temps la balle et je
fais un travail qui est un serment
ça part dans tous les sens
et puis au québec qu'une espèce de les
gens se sont familiarisés à ma
personnalité à mon travail petit à petit
tandis qu'ici je suis souvent venu sous
forme de petit flash très très précis
très momentané en fait
et puis justement le disque paris
tristesse et puis le fait sortir
ponctuent aussi sa marque une volonté de
peut-être passé plus de temps ici pour
équilibrer un peu les choses mais ce qui
se passe ici me plaît beaucoup ça me
plaît de savoir qu'à montréal je peux
pas marcher ça me fera connaître dans la
rue et puis qu ici si je me faire
connaître j'ai j'ai tendance à penser
que ce soit des québécois ou de vrais
mélomanes